[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo ravi de vous
retrouver pour un tour d'horizon de
l'actualité de la semaine dans le
département
tout de suite les titres de ce vendredi
5 avril bonne nouvelle pour les
propriétaires de voitures électriques
elles s'installent dans les yvelines
elle devrait s'accroître cette année
grâce au déploiement du réseau du
syndicat d'énergie des yvelines pendant
trois jours se déroule la 25e édition du
sidaction mais samedi c'est aussi la
journée mondiale de la maladie de
parkinson raideurs musculaires
ralentissement des mouvements ou encore
tremblements nous recevront en plateau
jean jacques buts signés membres du
comité france parkinson des yvelines
visible du 3 d'expérience lab de
dassault systèmes première biennale
d'architecturé de paysage à versailles
ou encore nouveaux bus dans
l'agglomération
comme chaque vendredi coup d'oeil sur
l'actualité de la semaine
avant de débuter ce journal retour sur
le conseil communautaire de saint
quentin en yvelines il s'est déroulé
hier soir les élus ont notamment débattu
sur les taux de fiscalité concernant la
taxe d'habitation le taux restera en
2019 similaire à celui de 2018 avec 5,80
12%
même chose pour le taux de cotisation
foncière des entreprises il demeure à
23,20 % et des décisions prises afin de
préserver l activité et l'attractivité
du territoire selon la majorité
concernant la taxe d'enlèvement des
ordures ménagères le débat s'est révélée
plus houleux les différentes communes
devant parvenir un taux unique en 2021
certaines vont connaître plusieurs os à
montigny le bretonneux le maire a
exprimé sans succès le souhait de
reporter cette hausse
et puis côté mobilité on notera un peu
la vélostation en gare de saint quentin
en yvelines va proposer des offres
promotionnelles et des tarifs réduits
une offre vélio va aussi voir le jour
avec de nouveaux services recharger son
véhicule en pleine rue port marly à
sauter le pas la commune yvelinoise est
l'une des premières à s'être équipée
elle fait partie du réseau
c'est ma borne un programme
d'installation de bornes électriques du
syndicat d'énergie des yvelines et
d'aînés 10 mélanie poké et michael et
demi d'euros un geste que port marly
aimerait voir se développer la commune
de 6000 habitants vient de se doter de
deux nouvelles bornes de recharge pour
les véhicules électriques
nous sommes traversés par deux voies à
grande circulation et
avec ce que cela comporte comme
nuisances pollutions sonores évolution
de l'air ça nous conforte évidemment
dans une action et cette action en
faveur des véhicules électriques est
évidemment important pour nous un
dispositif accessible grâce à un badge à
prendre auprès du syndicat d'énergie des
yvelines plus de 140 bornes seront
installées d'ici la fin de l'année 2009
dans le département
parce que le développement à grande
échelle des bornes électriques comme le
prévoit d'ailleurs la récente le récent
projet de programmation pluriannuelle
d'énergie à l'horizon 2030 ces sept
millions de bornes qui sont prévus 7
millions de bornes il faudra des
raccordés sur le réseau public
d'électricité et donc ça nécessitera
d'adapter ce réseau le budget global de
l'installation dans le département est
estimé à 1 million d'euros 76 autres
communes sont concernées dont maurepas
et plaisir troubles du sommeil de la
tension modification de l'humeur ou
encore tremblements la maladie de
parkinson est une maladie
neurodégénérative ce samedi se déroule
la journée mondiale de la maladie de
parkinson avec nous pour en parler en
plateau jean jacques petit nid bonjour
bonjour vous êtes membre du comité et
france parkinson des yvelines et vous
souffrez également de cette maladie
quels sont vos symptômes alors les
symptômes sont un peu sont déjà
progressif mais ils sont
caractéristiques de la maladie c'est à
dire on a des mouvements qui sont
ralentis on a des tremblements on a
aussi dirigé dit et des blocages enfin
et c'est donc on a la liste n'est pas
exhaustive
la pathologiste où chacun de manière un
peu différente
et alors la particularité de la maladie
c'est qu'en plus de ses caractéristiques
générales
on a aussi des non linéarité de l'état
dans la journée c'est à dire qu'on a des
périodes où on est un peu commun
hier et teinté allumé se rappelle anne
wolf et donc c'est difficile de
planifier sont ajournés en conséquence
et puis chaque malade a des
caractéristiques particulières comme je
le disais donc il est important pour les
malades de bien connaître ses propres
caractéristiques pour pouvoir en parler
avec les professionnels de santé
et puis que soient bien aller coûte pour
adopter le traitement les troubles de la
marche parkinsonienne touchent plus d'un
million de personnes en europe
vous avez donc des douleurs fréquentes
si ce n'est quasi permanente qu'elle est
plus dure pour vous alors le plus dur
c'est à dire surtout au niveau de la
lenteur des mouvements et puis les
douleurs va c'est qu'elles sont ils sont
de nature vous avez donc les douleurs
qui sont spécifiques de la maladie comme
par exemple quand vous êtes un peu plus
rigide où ça que ça génère des crampes
donc ça c'est des maladies c'est un
exemple mais qui montre que c'est seydou
leur sont spécifiques de la maladie
et en plus quand on a atteint de la
maladie de parkinson une sensibilité
supérieure aux douleurs habituel c'est
adoptant un impact social fort alors oui
parce que on est quand même plus plus
- - mobile comme je disais on a plus de
difficultés à planifier ses activités
et puis quand on est en public c'est
très compliqué parce que quand vous avez
quelque chose à payer ben on le voyait
dans le reportage d'introduction on
tremble on renverse enfin a du mal à
fabriquer ces gestes donc ça prend du
temps ça agace les les clients qui sont
derrière donc voilà donc l'objet de
l'objectif c'est de changer un peu la
connaissance que le public a de cette
maladie pour adapter son comportement
aussi ne pas se sentir seul malgré la
maladie pour parler de vos douleur est
ressentie des réunions d'information et
d'échangés entre malades sont organisées
dans les yvelines plupart ticket par
ticulièrement à versailles et
rambouillet et yann plantec a animé une
réunion à rambouillet et m'a fait part
d'un constat écouter la maladie pas bien
qu encore connue les médecins nous
verrons peut-être un ou deux patients
dans leur carrière donc c'est pas mal
c'est pas énorme mais quand même de
120000 malabo en france les neurologues
sont plus spécialisés dans la vie
parkinson mais pas tous donc l'annoncé
du diagnostic c'est déjà un choc et
après on trouve des gens qui sont pas
forcément sensibilisé à cette maladie
particulière une réaction que
pensez-vous de la prise en charge de
cette maladie alors je confirme ce que
dit yann c'est vrai que les
professionnels de santé ne sont pas tous
au même niveau d'information sur cette
maladie
donc il faut d'ailleurs les réunions
mensuelles des changes permettent
justement de donner les bonnes adresses
des professionnels qui peuvent vraiment
nous accompagner j'avais complété il ya
exactement il ya encore deux autres
comités antennes dans les yvelines qui
sont sur mantes la jolie et saint
germain en laye qui organise aussi des
réunions mensuelles des changes c'est
important parce que ça réunit les
malades et leurs proches mais ça permet
aussi d'avoir plusieurs visions
2 les effets de la maladie comment on
peut s'en sortir et c'est alors vous
l'avez dit pendant ces réunions vous
échanger les bonnes adresses de
praticiens également ostéopathe hypnose
relaxation ou encore sophrologue mais
aussi des lieux pour pratiquer une
activité physique
steve et stimuler vos muscles c'est
important leur effectivement donc on
pense rappelle rapidement aux approches
thérapeutiques donc les médicaments
éventuellement les opérations pour les
cas les plus extrêmes mais il ya des
compléments essentiel c'est l'activité
physique
et puis toutes les approches cognitives
et comportementales donc la relaxation
et des activités de mouvements comme le
yoga le tai chi chi kong donc ça c'est
très important ça permet de se
d'apprendre à se relaxer à se détendre à
oxygéner on parle de respiration donc
c'est quelque chose qui est très
important et qu'on appelle l'éducation
thérapeutique du patient de façon à
développer plusieurs approches enfin
plusieurs savoir à savoir pratique c'est
à dire connaître bien sa maladie pour
pouvoir en parler avec les
professionnels et à savoir faire aussi
théorique qui est facile d'y recevoir
pratiquer des activités physiques savoir
théorique c'est à pouvoir en parler avec
les professionnels un savoir agir ou
réagir c'est à dire quand en situation
de stress va comment on doit pouvoir se
comporter sans être débordés et puis un
savoir-être c'est à dire que ce que
disait yann est exact c'est un choc
donc il faut voir arriver à accepter cet
état et puis arrivèrent vivre avec
donc on peut pas être en permanence en
dix ans avant c'était j'étais comme ça
maintenant je suis comme ça parce que
l'on déprimerait vite donc il faut
arriver à une phase d'acceptation et
puis de positive à sion de l'avenir pour
vaincre cette maladie il n'y a pas que
les médicaments
surtout qu'en ce moment il ya des
pénuries alors effectivement il n'ya pas
que les médicaments
d'autant que les pénuries de médicaments
sont récurrentes et donc l'association
par la voix de son président avait des
actions aux fortes auprès des autorités
de santé
donc en résumé ce qu'on peut regretter
c'est que la france n'a pas 20
dépendance d'approvisionnement ou de
sécurité d'approvisionnement les
médicaments sont majoritairement
fabriqués à l'étranger et on est
dépendant des décisions de ces
laboratoires étrangers pour la
fourniture aux médecins aux malades ce
samedi 6 avril c'est la journée mondiale
de la maladie de parkinson il y aura un
stand représentant les yvelines sur
l'événement à la cité des sciences à
paris lors de cette journée que propose
france parkinson
alors il y aura plusieurs stands donc il
ya effectivement le comité france
parkinson des yvelines qui sera parmi
les autres comité ile de france
il y aura des stands pour mieux
comprendre la recherche spécifique pour
parkinson
il y aura effectivement aussi il était
un stand pour l'écurie cure parce que
c'est efficace aussi et puis des
librairies
ensuite il y aura bien sûr des
conférences prêts très intéressante donc
une conférence le matin sur les aspects
psychologiques et cognitives de la
maladie donc par thierry guetta qui est
psychologue et l'après midi on aura donc
deux conférences qui traite du thème
nouvelle approche dans la maladie de
parkinson
ça c'est important et ça se passe de 10h
à 17h30 à la cité des sciences et de
l'industrie et de paris l'entrée est
libre et gratuite
merci jean jacques pittini je le
rappelle vous êtes membre du comité de
france parkinson des îles depuis peu
merci notre invitation
aujourd'hui également c'est le lancement
de la 25e édition du sidaction pendant
trois jours ils rappellent comme leur
slogan l'indiquent que le virus du sida
est toujours là
le nombre de nouvelles infections chez
les 15 24 ans a augmenté de 24% depuis
2007 en france c'est également en hausse
chez les seniors de 22% depuis 2008 pour
soutenir la recherche et permettre un
accès aux traitements et aux soins pour
tous un numéro pour les dons le 110 et
tout de suite on passe au reste de
l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
l'établissement public d'aménagement
paris saclay organisé une visite ce
jeudi sur le thème de l'innovation à
vélizy-villacoublay dassault systèmes
permet à des start-up du monde entier de
profiter de ces technologies grâce aux
trois des expériences lab découverte
lancé par dassault systèmes il y un peu
plus de trois ans le 3 d'expérience la
bête un laboratoire d'innovation ouvert
basé à vélizy villacoublay
objectif pour le leader mondial des
logiciels de création 3d mettre sa
technologie au service de scientifiques
on a un modèle de coeur parfaitement
exact qui permet à des médecins et et à
des biologistes d'appréhender le
fonctionnement d'un coeur à des fins
pédagogiques ou pour préparer une
intervention sur ce campus dassault
systèmes accompagne également des start
up qui développe des produits physiques
capable d'améliorer la vie quotidienne
l'environnement urbain où les modes de
vie avec trois des expériences labels
peuvent bénéficier de l'aide d'experts
et spécialistes pour prototyper et
industrialiser leur innovation
l'objectif c'est de passer du niveau
local où on accompagne un réseau local
d'innovateur à un niveau global et faire
en sorte que ces écosystèmes puissent
collaborer les uns avec les autres ce
challenge et apprendre ensemble
entreprendre ensemble parce que vous
savez quand vous avez une bonne idée
quelque part ou pensait être le seul à
avoir l'idée au même moment de la
planète vous avez une dizaine d'autres
personnes qui ont exactement la même
idée est donc de faire rassembler c'est
important
rise robotics est une entreprise
américaine créée en 2011 à boston
spécialisée dans la robotique elle a
développé une technologie qui remplace
les système de vérins hydrauliques et
collabore avec dassault systèmes à
l'origine réalise utiliser solidworks
qui est un produit de dassault systèmes
pour design et nos prototypes et simuler
des tests avec le temps nous avons
trouvé des ressources nécessaires pour
des projets de management de fabrication
et plein plein de choses de dassault
systèmes pertinente pour rise robotics
aujourd'hui trois d'expérience lab
dispose également de bureaux physiques à
boston en inde et bientôt en chine
c'est une première le 4 mai prochain la
ville de versailles accueillera la
biennale d'architecturé de paysage de la
région ile de france une manifestation
se mêlera échanges rencontres et débats
aux quatre coins de la cité royale bape
trois lettres pour découvrir l'
architecture à travers des lieux de
patrimoine des colloques ou encore des
expositions la première biennale
d'architecturé de paysage de la région
ile de france ouvrira ses portes le 4
mai prochain à versailles un moment de
réflexion autour de ce thème l'homme la
ville et la nature
la grande interrogation aujourd'hui et
du moment en terme d'urbanisme
c'est le mariage entre la nature et
l'urbain et ça c'est devenu une question
prioritaire contenu de la préoccupation
écologique et donc tous les architectes
ou les urbanistes pensent différemment
depuis le début de ce nouveau millénaire
et ont mis la préoccupation
environnementale au coeur de leurs
travaux durant soixante et onze jours le
public pourra notamment à découvrir six
expositions réparties sur plusieurs
lieux au château de versailles
au potager du roi dans les écoles
nationales supérieures d'architecturé du
paysage
le choix de la cité royale pour
accueillir cette biennale s'est presque
imposé de lui même
la m ici dans cette école d'architecturé
cette école du paysage dans cette avenue
de paris où il y aura une lime qui sera
ordinaire et expositions photos la
relier au château de versailles au
potager du roi ça faisait du sens
et puis évidemment nous avons à
versailles des centaines de milliers de
touristes ce qui fait des centaines de
milliers de visiteurs potentiels pour la
biennale
lors de ce rendez vous le public pourra
également découvrir les projets les
ambitions du grand paris express lors
d'une exposition au sein de l'ancienne
poste
architecture toujours les travaux du
centre-ville de maurepas sont en cours
depuis octobre dernier des dizaines
d'ouvriers travaillent pour redonner une
nouvelle jeunesse au quartier la
livraison est programmée pour juillet
prochain les travaux du centre-ville de
maurepas avance depuis octobre dernier
des dizaines d'ouvriers travaillent pour
redonner une nouvelle jeunesse au
quartier l'ancien sol goudronné laisser
place à du granit et un nouvel escalier
déjà été construits c'est surtout de
redonner de la visibilité de commerce de
proximité parce que quand on arrive dans
le centre-ville de maurepas on s'est
aperçu qu'on avait un gros bouchon
qu'avait été construit dans les années
80 dans sa seconde phase avec vous savez
le bâtiment du kiosque fleury qui lui a
été détruit ou le le commerce de
proximité de des fleurs a été déplacé un
peu plus loin donc de retrouver de la
visibilité mais aussi de retravailler
les ambiances les éclairages de
replanter des arbres des plantes
bref de retrouver à centre-ville plus
qualitatif plus commerçants également au
total 64 commerces de la ville sont
concernés par ces travaux ce traiteur
est installé depuis 13 ans dans le
centre ville c'était des travaux qui
était nécessaire ça c'est vrai mais bon
un peu trop long en un délai c'est
surtout ça nous pour le commerce un
petit peu compliqué mais bon autrement
pour moi je sais c'est que du positif je
suppose que ça peut qu'embellir maurepas
coût total de l'opération 1,4 million
d'euros financé en partie par la région
et saint-quentin-en-yvelines la commune
investit quand elle 800000 euros dans le
projet ces huit cent mille euros qui
sont injectés pour l'avenir parce que là
on est vraiment sur une première phase
de restructuration du centre-ville parce
que évidemment il y aura d'autres
fassent dans les années qui viennent
parce qu'on se projette aussi à long
terme et c'est un investissement
vraiment à long terme et on en avait
bien besoin
la livraison définitive de ce centre
ville flambant neuf est programmée pour
le mois de juillet vous les avez
peut-être aperçu ou même emprunter un
design plus moderne et une conduite
silencieuse
trois nouveaux bus 100 % électrique ont
été mis en circulation ce lundi dans
saint quentin en yvelines
les premiers de la région ile de france
marylène iapichino vous embarque trois
nouveaux bus avec des sièges bleus pour
les places traditionnelles rouge pour
celles réservées aux personnes
prioritaires des lampes à led et même
des ports usb ile-de-france mobilité y
la ratp présenter les véhicules vendredi
29 mars
voilà donc voilà la prise la piste de
charge donc là vous branchez le bus
comme comme une voiture plus que leur
design extérieur la nouveauté vient
surtout de ce qu'ils ont sous le capot
des batteries
les bus du constructeur français sont
100% électrique
nous rentrons aujourd'hui dans une
nouvelle ère de transition énergétique
est véhicules propres et c'est là pour
nous l'occasion de rentrer dans cette
nouvelle ère aussi d'apprendre ces
matériels roulants qui sont nouveaux une
nouvelle technologie et d'en profiter
pour que nos conducteurs s'adapte à
cette nouvelle de technologie
aujourd'hui on a des vies que metric y
arrive on va avoir une expérimentation
sur des bus à hydrogène dans quelques
mois
et donc c'est important parce que on
peut pas continuer en ile de france a
tourné avec des véhicules diesel twitter
tout à 250 km d'autonomie pour des bus
qui circulent en moyenne entre 180 et
220 km par jour
ils seront rechargées au dépôt chaque
soir les chauffeurs apprennent dès à
présent à pratiquer une conduite
économique récupérer l'énergie hors
change et les matins vers vous avez une
conduite économique
orange et rouge sur les bateaux ces
trois bus sont les premiers du réseau
ile de france à être mises en
circulation de 12 mètres de long ils
peuvent accueillir 85 voyageurs c'est un
honneur pour 5 octobre
région donc à financer l'intégralité de
ses bus voilà les mettre à disposition
en premier de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
la région ile de france a pour ambition
d'équiper 100 % du territoire en
véhicules propres d'ici 2030 on passe à
présent reste de l'actualité en ile-de
france avec nos confrères devient grand
paris
[Musique]
pour se déplacer dans paris les
transports en commun sont toujours
plébiscités et la ratp a dévoilé son
bilan 2018 une fréquentation en hausse
notamment dans les métros pour se
déplacer à paris les transports en
commun ont toujours la cote
la ratp a dévoilé son bilan 2018
la fréquentation est en hausse dans le
métro plus 1,3 pour cent de trafic et
dans le tramway +6 5%
bilan plus contrasté dans l'air et les
bus si la ligne a engendré 4 millions de
trajets supplémentaires le rer b on a
perdu -1 7% du trafic voyageurs
les bus ont transporté moins d'usagers
une baisse de 0,6 pour cent ces six
millions de trajets en moins qu'en 2017
l'impact sur le chiffre d'affaires a été
un peu plus de 3 millions au t4
trimestre 4 et un peu plus de 3 millions
au trimestre ea donc oui on a vu
l'impact et pis ça a été surtout pour
nous un enjeu opérationnel puisque comme
vous l'avez vu on est arrivé à maintenir
le service public des bus en étant
extrêmement réactif sur les métros
évidemment n'était très coordonnée autre
bémol la crise des gilet jaune a fait
baisser la fréquentation dans les
transports en commun les samedis de
mobilisation de gros projets
d'investissement sont à venir sur le rer
b puisque nous sommes en train de
dépouiller la l'appel d'offres pour la
fin de l'année du changement de matériel
roulant qui permettra d'augmenter la
capacité de ce matériel de 25 ans ans en
la ratp a assuré plus de 3 milliards 389
millions de trajets nous passons à notre
rubrique ça s'est passé comme chaque
vendredi nous vous ouvrons les archives
de tv 78 et nous revenons en mars 2006
avec l'inauguration du nouveau centre
commercial
alpha parc aux clayes-sous-bois
[Musique]
nous sommes très heureux aussi beau
aussi bien sur le plan de la qualité au
niveau de l'environnement la qualité du
de l'architecturé du centre la création
d'emplois et la taxe professionnelle que
ça peut amener la ville décline
c'est une superbe réalisation
étroitement associé au projet depuis le
départ il ya quatre ans la municipalité
des clés peut en effet se réjouir de
l'arrivée de ce centre commercial
nouvelle vague
d'abord parce que c'est toute l'entrée
de la ville qui est ainsi complètement
métamorphosé son aspect architectural
particulièrement étudiée lui vaut
d'ailleurs le premier label valorparc
décerné en france ensuite parce qu'il
vaut 315 d'emplois dont plus d'une
centaine de créations pures
nous avons voulu faire quelque chose de
très différent de ce que l'on trouve
habituellement dans les entrées de ville
et dans le commerce de périphérie
c'est à dire que vous avez derrière vous
énormément dans scènes de périphérie
mais qui sont toutes reliées ensemble
par une promenade couverte est à la fois
découverte
cette promenade est longée par une
rivière la locomotive de ce nouveau
centre spécialisé maison et d'écossé
castorama qui a quitté plaisir pour
s'implanter sur une surface plus grande
huit autres enseignes se partagent le
second bâtiment dont cultura spécialisée
dans les loisirs créatifs mais aussi les
livres les disques et le multi média
cultura qui ouvre ici son premier
magasin dans les yvelines
quant à la concurrence avec le récent
skywest on affirme ici n'avoir aucune
inquiétude
[Musique]
avant de clôturer ce journal une idée de
sortie pour ce week-end un concept
inédit en ile de france vient de voir le
jour à fontenay le fleury
l'établissement baptisé copains d'abord
abrite un bar restaurant ainsi qu'un
barbier et un tatouage immersion avec
michael et demi d'euros à première vue
ce bar restaurant là rien d'original des
serveurs sont derrière le comptoir des
clients passent du bon temps en
dégustant leur boisson et pourtant
l'établissement est unique en ile de
france sa particularité les 250 mètres
carrés abrite également un barbier et un
tatoueur parce qu'on les quelque chose
qui change
on voulait pas juste faire un bar
restaurant on s'est dit pourquoi pas
mêlé le bar restaurant avec tout ça
histoire d'avoir vraiment un lieu de vie
où on peut venir boire un verre venir
manger on peut venir se faire couper les
cheveux ou se faire tailler la barbe et
éventuellement par un petit tatouage ce
concept hybride baptisé copains d'abord
en référence à georges brassens a été
créé par deux enfants du secteur avec un
objectif en tête développer la ville de
fontaine fleurie
un projet qui a séduit le coiffeur
barbier des lieux c'est vrai que dans
notre jeunesse on n'avait rien pour pour
bat pour se poser tout simplement est
passé des bons moments et puis bah voilà
le projet ils n'ont présenté exactement
de cette façon ça veut dire voilà tu te
souviens quand tu étais petit qu'est ce
que tu viens ici bas la réponse c'est
quoi sert à rien tout simplement et
et le fait de d'allier d'allier des
choses comme le tatouage le barber et le
marbre ça en fait un des endroits
branchés
depuis son ouverture le 21 mars le bar
tatoueur barbier attire plusieurs
dizaines de clients par jour
les plus téméraires sont même repartis
avec un petit souvenir pour un prix
compris entre 60 et 80 euros pour
l'instant il ya plutôt des petites à
tous et des flashs beaucoup donc des
dessins faits c'est si ce temps les gens
ont un coup de coeur et on l'est on
était tous à ce moment cette adresse
atypique prévoit d'organiser dans les
prochaines semaines des diffusions de
match des petits concerts ainsi que des
spectacles
toujours dans l'idée de répondre à la
devise du bar copains d'abord c'est la
fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo comme évoqué en
début de journal c'est la 25e édition du
sidaction ce week-end un numéro pour
faire vos dons le 110 très bon week-end
à tous
[Musique]
ouais